[Music]
this is star talk
cosmic queries edition neil degrasse
tyson here your personal astrophysicist
and i got chuck nice with me of course
what's up
faithful co-host
uh you know you're you're we need you
for the cosmic queries so that you can
mispronounce everyone's name well that's
my uh purpose in life neil
i live to butcher names you know
those poor questioners
so this this is the one packed up for
you how would you attack
my name
oh my goodness uh
so uh nick bostrom uh is that what she's
how is that how it is
it's it's pretty good that's pretty good
all right
in in in swedish it would be nicklas
postrum but that was close okay all
right uh and listen it i'll take clothes
as far as i'm concerned names are like a
game is better than yeah that's like a
game of horseshoes for me close
is good enough
good enough
so that was indeed nick bostrom chiming
in nick welcome to star talk dude you
started something that is got the whole
world spinning in a tizzy
for
birthing the concern that we all live in
a simulation
and let me just give a fast bio on you
uh you're a professor at university of
oxford
and in the future of humanity institute
oh that doesn't that's very kind of what
you know
sorry sorry nicholas not a lot of not a
lot of job security in that buddy
looking at the future humanity yo
[Laughter]
so you you think about artificial
intelligence um the ethics of of
artificial intelligence biosecurity net
what would have macro strategy we'll ask
you what that is in a moment just policy
ethics
uh foundational questions about
serious challenges that civilization
faces
not in the distant future but in the
very near future i like the fact that
you have a background in theoretical
physics so put you in the physics club
here that's good also computational
neuroscience wow we have some of those
at my home institution at the american
museum of natural history that's quite
the frontier
as well and you had a rather influential
paper research paper titled
are you living in a computer simulation
and for me also i remembered your book
super intelligence
which all of these
got people thinking as any good
philosopher should do
is to get people thinking
and so
could you just
start us off
why do you think we might be living in a
simulation well
i have this thing called the simulation
argument which doesn't actually
prove that we're in a simulation but it
tries to show that at least one of three
propositions is true
the simulation
argument tries to show that one of three
propositions is true so let's let's
first look at what the conclusion is and
then we can see how we get there so the
conclusion is that either
almost all civilizations at our current
stage of technological development go
extinct before they become
technologically mature so that's like
one alternative right
the second is that
amongst civilizations that do become
technologically mature there is a very
strong convergence they all lose
interest
in creating a certain kind of computer
simulation i call them ancestor
simulations these would be
detailed simulations of people with the
kind of experiences that their
historical forebears had so that's the
second alternative and then the third
alternative is that
we are almost certainly living in a
computer simulation so so that that's
the kind of conclusion now how how does
one get to
to that well
suppose that
the first of these alternatives
does not obtain okay
so that means it's not true that almost
all civilizations at our stage failed to
reach technological maturity some
non-trivial fraction make it through
okay
all right then let's suppose that the
second alternative is also false so
amongst those who do become
technologically mature some non-trivial
fraction remain interested in using some
of the resources to create these kinds
of ancestor simulations then you can
show that the kind of computational
resources a mature civilization would
have
would suffice
to create
millions and billions of detailed
simulations ancestor simulations runs of
human history
and so that
if the first two alternatives are false
then
there would be many many more
simulated versions of people with our
kinds of experiences than that would be
original implemented in basic physical
reality
people with our experiences and
conditional on that
if almost all people with our
experiences are simulated
we should think we are probably one of
the simulated ones
rather than one of the rare
non-simulated ones so that means that if
you reject the first two alternatives
you would then have to accept the third
one and then that shows that
it's not
the case that all three of them are
false so hence at least one of them is
true so that that's the strategy why
can't why can't there be a fourth other
truth that no one gives a rat's ass
about simulating anything anywhere
exactly so that's the second right i
mean so if if all of these
technologically mature civilizations are
completely uninterested in in simulating
then that would be possibility number
two but but note that for the second
alternative to hold it's not sufficient
that
most of them kind of are not very
interested
because even if it were just a one
percent of these mature civilizations
that were even a little bit interested
that they still could produce millions
of them and so that would have to be
this extremely strong convergence like
almost all of them would completely have
to lose any interest in doing this in
order for the second alternative okay
okay so so i have publicly mildly
butchered your line of argument there so
let me first apologize
uh what i had
been
noting
is that we
do not have the power yet to create a
perfect simulation
of a world
such as the one we're living in
and
so i wasn't thinking that everyone would
make these ancestor simulations which we
would be and so an ancestral
civilization in a in a cinematic
uh
parallel would be
uh a movie about spartacus or
cleopatra just some something
a movie which is modern technology
telling a story set in a time when they
didn't have movies right so that would
be like an i'm guessing that's what you
mean by an ancestor simulation and so so
i was thinking
that every single simulation would
ultimately be able to duplicate
themselves as a natural evolutionary arc
if that's the case
then we would either be the original
simulation except
then we would either be the original
universe that hasn't yet simulated
anybody yet or we'd be sort of the last
one simulated still working our way
towards the power of simulating
ourselves
which would be slightly better odds well
a lot better odds than
throwing a dart and landing in all the
simulations that had enough power to
create simulations of themselves
so first of all
i don't claim that the only simulations
that might be made are ancestor
simulations i mean that you i mean if
you imagine you are technologically
mature civilizations you might simulate
all kinds of things like
real histories as close as you can get
fantasy worlds counterfactual histories
imaginary alien civilizations i mean you
could
maybe there are like lots of all of
these kinds of simulations
um
the argument focuses on ancestor
simulations just because that's the
easiest way to get to the conclusion
that one of these three is true
but it doesn't imply that there wouldn't
be a lot of other simulations as well
okay so we we have some data with our
own
history of cinema and it's some very
small percent of movies are set in a
time
before movies were invented
which i would again i would classify as
sort of ancestor storytelling very it's
like in the low single digits so you
would say that there's so many movies
even the low signal digits is quite a
few
and you throw a dart we could easily be
one of those
yeah so i mean i guess
when we extrapolate to
these technologically mature presumably
post-human civilizations well first of
all
i'm not sure how much we can infer from
the kinds of movies we create to what
types of simulations they would run but
let's suppose for the sake of the
argument that the majority of
simulations they run
are of
people in their contemporary society so
it's a i don't know some super advanced
space colonizing thing with
super intelligence or whatnot and that
that's maybe the majority of what they
do but that they
assign some some smaller fraction of
their computational resources to doing
these ancestry simulations let's assume
that
um
i still don't think that would
defeat the
simulation argument um or indeed even
the alternative that we are in a
simulation because uh
um
we kind of already know that we are not
one of the
post-humans i mean you just look around
you don't see a lot of sort of starships
you know
whizzing by outside your window and we
are not currently running any
simulations ourselves
so we can kind of cross those out
like all the actual pulse humans we know
we're not one of those and we also know
we are not in a simulation of the
post-humans since
that's not the world we experience then
that leaves only
a the people in original history at the
human level of development and also
whatever ancestor simulations are at
that level of development
and so my claim would then be that you
know if the first two alternatives of
the simulation argument are false the
simulated ones
at our current level of development
would still vastly outnumber the
original ones at our stage of
development
so what is the likelihood that
not likelihood because that's the wrong
word is it possible that it could just
be the way that we create with our
limited technology
what we feel are simulations of our
lives okay and that's
computer games and video games and
things like that could it be that a
civilization so advanced
that they have the computational power
to create all of this
just for the hell of it
just because like the same way we do it
we do it for entertainment could it just
be that or is that just not a part of
the philosophy
uh it could be i mean so the the
simulation argument itself is agnostic
as to what the motivation would be okay
of the simulators and you could indeed
imagine many possible motivations one
one would be just entertainment
right and you could you could imagine
other like maybe some kind of research
like historically
uh maybe it would be interesting to
explore counterfactuals of history or or
you could imagine art project so you
could imagine moral reasons for i think
we know rather little about
the psychology and motivations of these
hypothetical post-human
civilizations and why they would make
simulations
um and we can speculate about that but
yeah either of those would work
for for the simulation argument too
okay so nick i guess you're allowed to
say all this like from your armchair but
at some point somebody wants to walk
into a lab and make a measurement that
says here's the evidence that supports
nick's argument
is there such
a
anything we can look for is there a sign
is there is there some experiment we can
conduct to say yep we're not in charge
of what's happening here this is a
simulation
there certainly is sort of empirical
premises that flow into the
simulation argument
and so evidence for or against the truth
of those assumptions
you know would be relevant to evaluating
the argument so so one empirical premise
um is that
a technologically mature civilization
would indeed have the capability
of creating
ancestor simulations and i need to
create lots of them
and so the kind of evidence that would
be relevant for that
is evidence say of the kind of
computational performance you could get
from physically possible systems we
we're not able to build them currently
but we can kind of
do first principle modeling of different
computational systems based on
nanotechnology and so forth and we can
place lower bounds on the kind of
compute power that they would unlock
so so that would be one
like
element that would flow into this
another would be some estimate of the
computational cost
of running an ancestor simulation
i think the
largest part of that cost is the cost of
simulating human brains at the
sufficient level of detail that the
simulation would be conscious
and we can obviously not precisely
determine what the computational expense
of simulating a human brain is but we
can place some upper bound on that we
have various views about
what computational tasks the human brain
is capable of performing we know how
many neurons there are how many synapses
how often they fire we can
we can roughly estimate that now it
turns out that
if you estimate the amount
of compute power available even if you
make rather conservative assumptions
about that and then you make
conservative assumptions about how much
it takes to simulate one human brain and
therefore how much to simulate all of
the human brains you just multiply that
by a hundred billion or something to all
of the human brains in history
there are a number of orders of
magnitude gap between these two so even
if you are off a little bit in these
estimates it still seems like the
the argument holds but so those would be
empirical premises that we could you
know theoretically obtain evidence
against like if we discovered the human
brain uses some kind of weird quantum
computation that is a lot more expensive
than that would flow into it then if in
addition you want to conclude not just
that one of these three alternative is
true which is all the simulation
argument itself says but if
more specifically you want to conclude
that we are in the simulation that the
third alternative is true then
there is an additional range of
empirical questions that become relevant
like anything that gives you evidence
against the first two
or in favor of the first two would be
then relevant evidence for evaluating
the third right so if we discover that
there is some kind of
uh big risk some doomsday mechanism that
we can ah now we realize this all
sufficiently advanced civilizations will
stumble on this new technology and
destroy themselves
that would be argument against the
simulation hypothesis because it would
make the first alternative more likely
well that'd be a really sad argument
against it because it would say here's
our proof we're not simulated we're
about to destroy
yeah now nick let me ask you this let me
ask you this nick
is it possible
that you are so smart that you are
constantly high and you don't know it
[Laughter]
i think in some
more or less metaphorical sense i think
that's
very likely to be true
if
pessimistic meta-induction right so if
you look at
all
humans who have been alive all eras
going back in time we can now see from
our current vantage point
basically they were all very wrong about
some big thing
i mean like starting with simple physics
they thought earth was in the center and
then like
basically we can see if we look back
more than 100 years we see that they all
got a whole bunch of really core things
wrong and it would kind of maybe be a
little bit presumptuous to think that
now finally we've gotten all of these
basic things right it seems more likely
that if people a thousand years from now
look back
at 2021 they will probably also see big
not just gaps in our understanding but
like things we were fundamentally
confused about and so yeah they'll laugh
their ass off everything we're talking
about right now yeah
or christ
so i do think we are in a fundamental
sense very much in the dark about the
really
biggest picture
um
still we we do what we try we'll take a
quick break and when we come back
uh we'll transition to our questions
that we've solicited from our patreon
members and chuck has them all i i
haven't seen them i don't know if you've
seen them yet um nick either but
he's not here to try to stump us he's
here to just bring the enthusiasm of our
audience into the show so
okay
we'll be right back
we're back star talk i've got the one
and the only
nick bostrom that i generally regard it
as the person who birthed all of our
sleepless nights wondering whether we
are in a simulation
not only from his research papers but
from his books on the subject and he's a
professor at the university of oxford
and and chuck what do we call what is
the name of his thing here the future of
humanity institute which chuck and i are
pretty sure yeah would be very
short-lived yeah there's no future for
humanity
just before we get to the questions that
chuck has collected nick
if it's one thing to simulate all the
brains i get that
but it's another thing the fact that i
can go into a garden
and then look at a flower or dig through
the soils
and keep digging and reach the mantle of
the earth
whoever simulating us
has to simulate not only what my brain
is doing but
it has to simulate all the things my
brain is experiencing and that's not
just for me someone else could dig that
same hole and they should be finding the
same thing so isn't the total complexity
of the world doesn't that have to be
part of this simulation
even the fact that i as an
astrophysicist look out to the edge of
the universe decoding the nature of of
the big bang and all time and space that
followed it
so why just limit your estimates to the
power of the human brain if everything
and the unfolding of the great cosmic
story has to also happen alongside it
yeah i think you do need some
computation assigned to simulating
relevant parts of the environment
i think the biggest part will be the
brains but certainly if you had to
simulate the all of the environment
um
at subatomic detail continuously i mean
like quantum simulation of the entire
universe would be completely infeasible
if the um simulators have anything
comparable to the compute power that we
could realize in this universe
you know what i'm gonna disagree
i'm sorry i know you're a genius but
here's the deal
here's what i'm gonna here's what i'm
gonna disagree nick because when movie
makers make movies
they do not render the detail in every
single little thing what they have he
didn't get there yet
that was the next thing he was going to
talk about
now you already thought of this
like myself
jesus christ here i am here i am making
a discovery man
okay all right
okay continue wait chuck finish the
point and then we'll pick it up there go
well you got both of you already knew
where i was going but the deal is this
if you actually create a background that
background will pretty much be the same
for all the characters that are mapped
onto that background so that's the way
that's that's all i was saying
no i mean i i think that's the key for
uh to understand this whole simulation
argument stuff that if you had to
simulate all of the environment in
subatomic detail continuously it
probably would be completely infeasible
to do that but
i claim that's not needed
all you would need to do is to simulate
enough of the parts that we are
observing when we are observing them
that to the simulated creatures it looks
real and that they can't tell the
difference and that's a lot less all
right wait a minute i just thought of
something else inside so what that would
mean chuck
check what there it means if there are
whole sections of the pacific ocean
where there isn't a boat right right
then
no one has so it
it doesn't exist until someone until
somebody has to then see it and process
it right so it's a procedural content
generation so we use it in our computer
games today a lot like you often only
render the parts that some character in
the game are observing
um and maybe you have some very coarse
grain simulation of the whole thing
continuously but you may fill in details
if and when is needed so if like right
now i don't have any idea what the
atoms in this desk in front of me are
doing right but if i took in principle
an electron microscope or something i
could look and i better see atoms there
right but the program would know
programmer would know you're about to
bring out an electron microscope right
so time to up the calculation
right in the beam right there right and
if if necessary i mean they could even
pause the simulation or edit it or erase
memories if they really screwed it up
but yeah i think
um
the kind of capability would need to
even create anything resembling this
kind of simulation
is very advanced and i think with that
advanced capability would also come
the ability to edit and to
monitor human thoughts and intentions
and
then kind of be able to do this kind of
procedural generation that even we do in
our computer games today that could
explain why
um i've heard neil say this that we are
terrible data takers like as human
beings we are awful at taking in
information well if i'm programming a
simulation
i would certainly want to program the
people in that simulation to be like
that because that way i wouldn't have to
program all this detail into stuff
it protects
it protects the integrity of my
simulation
yeah
although i think to be fair i think the
difference between one human and another
from the point of view of the simulators
it's like well there is one and
it's got a few more neurons in this
genius and but i mean we are all like
ants i think uh so
i don't think this
difference in cost is that big
uh
cool very cool uh all right all right
chuck bring up bring on a question let's
see what you got all right here we go
let's uh let's jump into this this is
dennis uh gislane and dennis says this
spellback uh g-h-i-s-l-a-i-n
i said gislane
yeah is you just lane it's probably just
lane she's laying in this lane okay go
on well then it would be
just lane okay
we'd like to know
he says bring it on he says in his
papers dr bolstrom talks about
post-human stage civilization uh could
you please develop on that and situate
it in listen
uh kardashian of scale now i don't know
what any of that means
okay i can tell you what the kardashev
scale is what is the kardashians yeah
when i lead off with that and i'll hand
the baton over to you
nick so the kardashian scale is a scale
of how much energy you have access to
and can exploit
okay so i think they're five levels so
one of them is
do you have access to all of the energy
sources in your host planet and if you
do and you can exploit them your
civilization level one so that means you
can go into a volcano and tap the energy
you can tap the volcano the way you tap
a cake you could use the energy and the
crust of the earth that would otherwise
make volca
earthquakes you can tap that and use
that for your own means uh storm systems
this sort of thing
so a level two civilization would
control
all of the energy that comes from its
host star
okay okay that's way more energy than
what is embedded in your planet a level
three civilization would control all the
energy
of your galaxy that you happen to live
in so the the levels of the flag will
let the center of the galaxy you could
use yeah well yeah exactly exactly and
you wield this and the history of
civilization reveals that the
the nations or the nation-states that
had the most power
power political power cultural power
were those that
that actually wielded the most energy
per capita
in the world at that time
so when people say united states we're
such energy hogs we use you know four
times there five times the energy as
anybody else well that correlates
with other
measures of power that exist in it so
let's keep going so one more uh there's
level four level five if you control all
the energy of the universe and then
you know you're indistinguishable from
a god that anyone would have uh uh
suggested now so what are we
we're digging fossil fuels out of the
earth
we're level point five we're level point
three we don't know we're level zero
okay we're level zero okay so nick if
there's a super intelligence presumably
they have better access to energy
especially the kind of energy you're
talking about they might need this
simulation so have you thought about
where a superintelligence might fit on
the kardashev scale yeah i mean i think
that would be higher up just because at
that level you would be able to run a
lot more of these simulations
even if there were some simulations run
by i don't know a kardashian scale
one civilization like with the dyson
sphere around their south and that's all
they did
you know
once the civilization expands beyond
that they could run
billions of times more and there would
be plenty of time for them to expand
beyond that so
you could imagine almost all simulations
that are on are being run by
civilizations that have reached the
limits of whatever space they have to
expand into that that would presumably
be kardashian4 or something unless the
universe is so crowded that each one
only manages just to
to get a sort of galactic level volume
before it bumps up against its neighbors
yeah that's a good point because you can
only have one
galactic kardashian-scale civilization
because anyone else who wants it too bad
we're using all the energy it's like
in the united states right now there's
fights over the colorado river basin
because it's a water sauce that river
flows through multiple states and
each state has a pact with the other
state how much water they're supposed to
use and then there'll be future fights
on access to this one source of fresh
water and so that's an interesting point
you can't have a universe filled with
high kardashev level civilizations
because they would implode rapidly it
seems to me and what level is death star
what what what level is death star on
the uh kardashian scale oh
well in in star wars episode seven it
controlled the energy of a star so that
would be i guess level two that's the
only level two wow
awesome okay here we go let's uh let's
jump right back by the way in star trek
the borg were
that's a super intelligence that
was
cosmic
in its influence and so that would be a
even even higher here right just to put
that in context so chuck give me another
one you got another okay this is william
d a
uh quite easy
but letters here we go he says where do
you stand on the concept of
consciousness and where do you draw the
line would a simulated reality change
your definition of what possesses
consciousness i like that so nick is
psychic
i presume that means that somehow
consciousness is a shared entity
that we all participate in as one
uh uh panzer is organizing there are
different sort of definitions but it's
probably the view that everything is
conscious
oh wow um
uh i don't
and so how do you how do you put
consciousness in is that a natural out
flow of a sufficiently
uh complex computer simulation of the
brain
that would be my sort of the default
assumption yeah yeah i mean i think for
the simulation argument you can kind of
plug in whatever your favorite theory of
consciousness is and most of them would
work
um
there might be some
theories of consciousness which would
not work
the simulation argument
one of its assumptions is what i call
the substrate independence thesis which
is just the idea that in principle you
could implement consciousness not just
on
you know carbon-based biological
structures but on any suitable
computational structure
that what makes us conscious is not that
we're made of carbon but that our brains
perform a certain type of computation
whoa
holy crap
wait a minute yeah max ted mark has i
was about to say subject
uh yeah yeah you're a friend of star
talks yeah and his thing is like the
entire universe is made of math because
it goes down to particles and these
particles have spin and
you know so you can assign a value to
them uh mathematically mathematical
entities yeah yeah there's good overlap
there yeah yeah okay but as to where to
draw the line like i don't really
have a very good account of exactly
something i think humans are conscious
and rocks are not conscious but like
exactly where
sort of in the hierarchy
uh that would be cut off i'm not sure or
i'm not sure either that there is a
sharp line there it might more be that
there is kind of diminishing or
more and more strained senses in which
lower order organisms
have some kind of consciousness and it
kind of fades out rather than there
being a sharp threshold is what i
would guess but
so here's here's what i wonder nick i
just have a
a
not deeply thought out hypothesis
that
having thoughts
such as we do
that are incomplete and
that we wander and we don't have good
memory of things or we make stuff up the
fact that it's not perfect
we interpret as consciousness
because if it were perfect it's just
data and our brain is a storage disk
that occasionally
puts information together with a new
result
but the fact that we we can sit there
and say well i feel this and i don't and
it's mostly
how we reckon
our with our ignorance of our
environment even when we probe it for
knowledge
i'm just putting it out there yeah well
i mean i guess first of all you could
have
i mean a lot of artificial
even simple systems that would be
imperfect in various ways you could have
some faulty hard drives that
randomly erase various things
um
you could also have kind of compressed
representations that's what you have to
do if you're trying to do anything with
ai is there's a lot of data coming in
and you have to extract
some important features based on that
and throw the rest away so
these things
wait wait check with chuck
what nick just said i can't stop
thinking about it so
so chuck every time you and i forget
something right
the alien's hard drive messed up
so every time you go what what did i
come upstairs for
it's it's a it's a right it's a it's a
read write error an i o error in a
programmer's disk wow
i don't think this is
your account of consciousness that
somehow what's necessary or sufficient
for consciousness is that there is some
kind of faulty or limited information
processing right right otherwise it's a
perfect computer well um
i'm saying that computers are also
imperfect in certain ways and
um i'm not sure that the closer you get
to
perfection like you would lose
consciousness i think in anything it
might go the other way around that you
might become more conscious if you want
more but yeah you might have to if you
wanted to sort of um
elaborate on that you might want to try
to say like which types of imperfection
are the ones that are supposedly making
a system conscious um and maybe
maybe exploring that line of thought
further maybe you would get to something
that would be
uh
some kind of possible account of
consciousness i'm not sure oh yeah in
the film in the film irobot forgive me
for not having read the original series
of short stories but in by isaac asimov
but in the film they hypothesize what
could account
for free will
in a programmed robot and they were
describing how many generations of
operating systems
are layered on top of one another and
there's always these dangling parts
that
you know you don't always clean it up
after because it's evolution is like
this too the they're dangling parts that
worked at some point now you don't need
them or that like they could get in the
way or they can end up killing you but
programmatically they could be lines of
code that have long lost their utility
but could manifest under certain
combinations of stimuli
that
look like the robot just thought of a
new idea
and i was intrigued by that suggestion
when i heard it in the film
that that could be the way
you end up with what we call uh
consciousness but hey we've got to take
another break when we come back for the
third and final segment uh we're gonna
go through a lightning round with our
questions and it's it's nick bostrom
just schooling us on whether or not
we're in a simulation and
uh spoiler alert it sounds like we kind
of are
it sounds like
yeah okay when star talk returns
we're back star talk i've got nick
bostrom in the house actually he's in
the uk right now but he's in he's in our
zoom house
and we're talking about the simulation
hypothesis
and
which he's largely
started
okay
and so we blame him for all of our lost
sleep at night i at least i nick i blame
you if no one else does so uh
so nick the simulation hypothesis
requires that every simulation has
computers right
why is that an obvious thing in fact
we've only had computers for like half a
century
and we've been human for a couple
hundred thousand years in our current
form
why should it be inevitable that a
computer is the thing that gets invented
that then people want to simulate on
i mean i don't know that this is
inevitable maybe if there are a lot of
humanoid species that never developed
computers i
i don't know i mean
it suffices that
some
civilizations do develop computers and
then more advanced computers
of the type we can already see are
physically possible although we cannot
build but certainly it's consistent with
a lot of civilizations failing to reach
even our stage of development
um i mean i think if you're asking about
inevitability even if it's not relevant
for the simulation argument it's kind of
interesting like it you want to i guess
define what what point
in time if it's inevitable
like it seems like the further back you
go if you sort of re-ran evolution from
that point
the less likely that you would get
something similar to what we have today
if you started with just bacteria like
in who knows maybe the chances would be
very small perhaps
that you would get an intelligent
technological species but if you started
like 50 000 years ago then i mean my
guess would be we were already pretty
well underway and
it was just a matter of oh that's an
interesting interesting point okay
because the contingencies of evolution
uh right it would take in fact if it if
the asteroid didn't hit 65 million years
ago the dinosaurs would be here and we
wouldn't for sure
they have been having this conversation
they need a slightly bigger brain yes
but rather than all that proverbial
walnut-sized brain that they had but
clearly
they would still be here they having
been around for several hundred million
years before the asteroid so but yeah
you take it late enough nick that's a
good argument started 50 100 000 years
ago
uh it's i'm i'm good with that
we surely that there'd be some
evolutionary paths and just for those
who are et fans
uh consider that we all would judge the
roman empire to be an intelligent
civilization
yet
aliens trying to communicate with them
with radio waves would conclude that
there's no technology on earth right so
we spent a lot of time being smart but
without the technology
and so that's the real question how much
longer do we have technology before we
exterminate ourselves
but anyhow chuck give let's this is
cosmic queries bring it on okay nick
we're gonna try to bang out a whole lot
in this in this third and final segment
so let's try to keep the answers tight
okay all right bring it down all right
this is dylan and gordonville gonna mash
up their questions hello everyone from
new uh albuquerque new mexico i'm a
senior in high school and this question
has been bugging me forever do we have
free will or is everything set in stone
are we living a predetermined life if we
are in a simulation and then gordon vu
says on top of that if we manage to
prove that we are living in a simulation
does that mean there is or is not a god
thank you
talking about some philosophical big big
big gun questions
theological philosophical so nick i love
those questions what do you have to say
about yeah well i mean on the latter i
think it
it wouldn't prove
or disprove god i think it's an
independent question whether we are in a
simulation versus
um whether god exists so i don't see any
necessary connection there on the
freewheel
i think
we would have as much free will
in the simulation as we would with
without the simulation um i'm
a compatibilist to myself so i think
that even if we are living in a
deterministic physical universe that
that would be consistent with us having
in the relevant sense free will but you
might have a different view on the
metaphysics of free will but i
i don't think the
fact that we would be in a simulation
would necessarily change that well but
so but would that mean that the
programmers of that simulation
would program into our brains a
perception of free will even if they
know the outcome in advance uh at every
moment
i don't think that we would need to
especially program that did i mean for
the same reasons we if we are not in a
simulation
we would have this
this notion of free will the people in
the simulation would presumably develop
that for for the same kind of reasons
um i mean it connects obviously to
holding people accountable for certain
things they do i mean if you stumble
into somebody and bump them
we say well you're excused because you
didn't intend it but if you go and punch
them and achieve the same bruce then you
will be held accountable because that's
something you did of your own free will
um
and so and we make choices that we have
to actually
internally
come up on a certain decision so all of
those
things would hold equally true for
people in the simulation as as people
outside the simulation right side
if you have this way of free will that
wouldn't really be a difference i think
all right okay all right chuck give me
some more uh and nick you're doing great
with the short answers good okay oh wait
wait let me go back to the god one wait
so why can't just the programmers be
indistinguishable from god
if they have power over everything yeah
uh that i mean depending on
what you make into the concept of a god
yeah in many ways that would be
analogous
to
how some people have traditionally
conceived
of god right in the sense that they
would kind of have created
our world
um although they wouldn't have created
the whole world just the parts that we
see
they would presumably
maybe not be omniscient but they would
know a lot like they could sort of see
everything that is going on inside our
simulation and they would
not be omnipotent they would themselves
be subject to
the physical constraints operating at
their level of reality but they could
intervene in our reality including in
ways that contravene the laws of physics
that we perceive but so in one sense and
thereby producing miracles and that
would be interesting yeah but the things
that appear to us in the simulation as a
miracle so in one sense there is a kind
of structurally similar relationship on
the other hand they would be
subject to all these they would
presumably be finite and subject to all
these kind of limitations and
constraints and in that sense kind of
being infinitely far removed from a lot
of the
traditional conceptions of god which is
like a literally infinite and omnipotent
and omniscient being
um so i think that whatever the truth is
about the simulation hypothesis it
wouldn't settle the question of whether
there is
this this kind of more traditionally
conceived literally infinite god
okay perfect there you go okay chuck
keep it going uh frederick johansson
wants to know is
general a.i really a question about
hardware and processing speed if it was
wouldn't a computer to today be able to
simulate a few seconds of a.i
like it had a thousand years to process
yeah um it's a good question um i think
compute is
a very important
factor in driving ai progress over the
last
eight years or so with the whole deep
learning revolution i think it's maybe
two thirds of the progress we've seen is
due to uh we are applying more compute
and then maybe one-third is algorithmic
progress
um
it's not
it even if it were all
computer it doesn't necessarily follow
that
we would be able to with our current
compute run at least a small fraction
of a human level mind
because
there are two things you need to compute
for so one is to run the ai right like
to actually have it do but you also need
to train up the neural network that
becomes the ai so if you don't have
enough uh compute to do the full
training run
you might not even be able to develop
the system which then if run would
constitute some kind of human equivalent
level agi
right because the calculation or the
decision is not made in a vacuum it's
it's been completely pre-loaded
with the world's life experience or
whatever
is sitting right behind that one
decision isn't is that a fair way to
think about this
well so for humans to arrive at some
sort of normal adult level of
performance we need 20 years or 15 years
to kind of grow up
and learn
and
our current neural networks are similar
in that although they are probably less
efficient in learning so they might need
instead of 15 years of experience maybe
they need like a thousand years
equivalence although you can run it
faster but you still need a lot of
compute just to be able to complete
something analogous to like a human
maturation process so even if we had
enough compute to run a agi a human
level ai we might not have enough
compute to sort of
create it
i think also though in addition to more
compute we also need some additional
algorithmic insights but
it's not all or nothing like like the
better the algorithms the less compute
you need to achieve this result and
right now the amount of compute you need
would be
like way more than we can currently
afford and then it comes down as we make
algorithmic progress
at the same time as our computers become
faster and at some point you'll
these lines will intersect
you just made a point embarrassingly
clear that humans require
like a fourth of our lives just to
function as participating humans and
civilization that's that's embarrassing
but true
right right you no one trusts your
decisions you make until you're at least
20.
and even then some for some
people never
yeah i mean the brains are really not
working even after
right as a kind of
collective we have just kind of barely
you know
uh intelligence to be able to
create
a technological civilization
i think we look like we're right on the
cusp of that
and it's not so surprising maybe because
like if you imagine our ancestors had a
lot less abstract reasoning ability and
it gradually improved over biological
time scales right and then as soon as we
became capable
of creating a technological civilization
then we pretty much did it or after you
know 10 000 years or something so so we
should kind of maybe expect that we are
at the lower end of what is needed to do
this at all
and that maybe explains some of what we
see in the world that we're kind of
fumbling our way a lot of what we see in
the world yes yes
all right chuck give me more more i've
got a few minutes left skyler gravatt
says if this is a simulation why are the
people
running the simulation so patient the
universe is estimated to be 13 point
something billion years old and they
waited almost 10 billion years
to simulate life
huh
well so first
uh there's no particular reason to think
that those ten million years were
simulated they could just have started
picked up
at a later point right you don't need to
do it from the
big bang onwards you could start the
simulation from a later point
but you'd embed the simulation with
evidence that that simulation scientist
would then interpret as an old universe
but it's all just fake yeah obviously
you probably don't want to show through
like 10 billion years of just uh gas
clouds congealing like that would be a
pretty
kind of boring right yeah
but even even when you get into the um
say that we're interested like
in all of human history right for the
sake of the argument that that's the 100
thousand years ago
onward like doesn't mean that for them
it would take 10 000 years to do this
they could run the simulation at a
higher speed like maybe
you know one minute of their time
could could simulate a thousand years it
depends on how fast the computer is that
you run the simulation on
right so when we
had a great revelation when computing
power
was adopted by astrophysicists in the
1970s we were early out of the box on
this there were these galaxies in the
universe that were kind of funky looking
and we made catalogs called peculiar
galaxies we didn't you know
maybe we just thought galaxies were made
that way only after we were able to
simulate the collision of two galaxies
did we realize that this is like the the
the crash scene
leftovers of what happens when galaxies
collide and we simulate
a billion years in a matter of minutes
and in so doing we were able to populate
the entire catalog of galaxy parts and
and nasty twisted looking galaxy forms
simply by seeing what happens when they
collide and speeding up the time to do
so that's just a little aside i thought
wow
are you patient or what this is
nathaniel mitchell who says if we could
ever simulate an exact replica of our
universe down to the spin on the
components of quantum particles could we
speed it up and then use it to predict
our future as we now do with simulations
for climate and otherwise but yet on a
cosmic scale
well so that kind of thing wouldn't fit
into our universe like a computer that
simulated all of our universe
it wouldn't be possible to build that in
our universe
that's a philosophical challenge that's
like saying well yeah i mean how
detailed do you want your map to be
right if you have a map the size
of the uk
then it have all the detail of the
actual
island
but then you could just
use the island right the map is no
longer useful to you you like that so
you yeah i mean i mean so and yeah i
think it would be very infusible to
simulate our world at the level of you
know
quantum properties at least if the
simulator's universe looked
anything like our universe
but maybe the physics at that their
level of reality is different i mean
maybe they have more maybe it's possible
to build more powerful computers
in at we could even imagine hyper
computation being possible in some
other kind of physics so that they could
run literally infinite computations and
then maybe they could simulate a world
like ours at full quantum detail but
that and then run it forward and watch
the future everything i mean from our
point of view it would
presumably not make much difference
whether they did it that way or the much
cheaper way that would only
render things at a sufficient
level to be convincing to the people
inside
and in fact even if you imagine that
there were some simulators that could do
this
at full quantum detail it would cost
them so much more compute
that it would still likely be the case
that almost all stimulations would run
in the more efficient way
that would only simulate things at the
coarser grain so so even if there were
some fully full grain simulations we
would probably be in one of the other
ones because that would be a lot cheaper
and so you could create orders of
magnitude more
and how much of this relates to the fact
that it's hard for something to
understand itself
like can the brain
the human brain actually
come to understand the human brain
is that or do you need a higher
intelligence than the human brain to
then study the human brain as a thing
outside of itself
understanding is a matter of degree
right so we know some things about
ourselves and obviously there's a lot
that we don't know
and
we understand a bit about ourselves now
we could understand more i mean
obviously you couldn't have a full
simulation of all the details in the
human brain stoved away in a part of the
human brain right that
that's i guess that's that's that's the
map of the uk that would be as big as uk
yeah if you wanted all the details right
right i've been to paradise but i've
never been to me
thank you chuck
so we got to land this plane let me just
offer
my best evidence for why i think we live
in a simulation
we're going to go public on this
i think right when civilization is kind
of
going smooth
then
something happens
okay a politician rises up there's a war
there's a world war there's
tsunamis and i think they
the aliens
program that in for their own
entertainment because that's what we did
in the sim
in the sim games in sim city where
you're mayor of a city and everything's
going fine
on announce godzilla
trout trounches through your city and
now you have to deal with it the fire
and the police and the to rebuild the
schools and that's you
running the software
um no the programmer sending that in
without telling you that's going to
happen i think all of the troubles we
have in the world is evidence
that the programmers need entertainment
yeah well nick uh like i said we got to
land this plane thank you for coming out
to star talk this conversation was long
overdue i wanted to get you a few years
ago but you were in high demand and you
still are for sure
but um if if any of us discover
something like a we part the curtain and
we see
like a cpu there that when it was
supposed to be a couch
i'll call you up
if anybody hearing that does that
contact neil rather than me i
[Laughter]
for sure all right it's been a delight
uh nick is is the super intelligence the
book you would have people sort of check
out in terms of the foundations of this
thinking yeah well not specifically on
the simulation argument there the
article is online just google it
simulation argument you'll find it um
but if you want to read a book about the
future of ai and stuff
then super intelligence would be the one
i would point to excellent excellent all
right good and chuck we can find you a
chuck nice comic on twitter thank you
sir and everywhere else yes social media
excellent all right uh nick again thanks
for joining us i'm glad we could do it
yeah
yeah finally this cosmic queries episode
i'm neil degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist as always
keep looking up
[Music]
you